and our first look at cooper criswell
the 25 year old out of north carolina
he's had a pretty good season both in
double a and triple a osmore of course a
veteran
right up the middle right into the shift
and the youngster gets out of trouble on
the mound for the padres is no no joe
musgrove 25th start for the right-hander
he
recorded the win last time out against
the phillies to even that record at
eight and eighty pitched a solid six
innings joe has been really consistent
all year long
swinging a miss and a nasty pitch right
there that's a good curveball reel 12 to
12-6
one and one to grisham left-hand hitter
lines it into left-center field that'll
be a base hit maybe extra bases we'll
see takes a turn though mars the center
fielder got there in a hurry but a
really well-struck single the other
direction
kim hits it on the ground in the left
center field a base hit out of the range
of iglesias back up the middle and
grisham will take second base two on one
away for the friars here in the second
inning one out two on and that'll bring
up jerks and profar one out two on
profile waiting on a 3-1
and a liner that is a fair ball down the
right field line to the corner
grisham being waved around he will score
and they're going to try and score kim
all the way from first base throw will
go to the plate it is late and the
padres take a two nothing lead pro far
ends up at third base
middle middle in
and he was flirting with one before this
one stays fair everybody is off and
running
bobby dickerson i'll tell you what he's
going to need shoulder surgery after
that ball hit down the line tell him to
get down but the plays at the plate not
even close and the padres are on the
board
jake making his fourth start as a padres
is being acquired from the cubs around
the deadline
two and two heartache grounder through
the left side and past the drawn in
infield out into left field for a base
hit mariznick an rbi single in his first
hit bat of the night three to nothing
padres in a second
and even with the infield in jake
marisdick hits this ball hard enough to
get through two pitch coming up to
justin upton the former padre
and that is wow strike three thank you
[Applause]
wow
yeah swinging a miss iglesia strikes out
that's three straight strikeouts from
musgrove two down here in the second
inning
swinging to miss celibate at the
fastball and strikes him out ends up
striking out the side
ground ball softly hit right side glove
to glove will work
profarna hosmer gloved a glove two down
oh that's got such a beautiful ring to
it
say it again donny glove to glove
it's a beautiful sight
jerickson likes it
runner on will bring up eric hosmer
erica is grounded out twice once to
short once back to the mound oh for two
chopped to second base could be two
second for one
yes
they got the one but he dropped it on
the transfer did iglesias
so just the one the ruling the by the
second base umpire ed hickox
and we'll see if chase is going to
challenge this or not
whether or not just glanced off the
globe or whether it was truly on the
transfer
as ed hickox said and they are going to
challenge
so we'll see
oh he never had control did he don
i don't know that's tough in slow motion
looks like it's in the glove a lot
longer than it probably was
in real time so he's got it in the glove
there and he goes to get it with his
bare hand
and he's safe at second base so
he's not on the transfer and the padres
able to get that call overturned
2-0 here's the pitch and he lines it
through the left side for a base hit
kind of split fletcher and iglesias both
of whom were there nanny rounding third
he'll come in to score rbi single austin
nola and the padres do cash in on the
opportunity it's four to nothing and
still runners on first and second with
nobody out that's what you like to see
the angels make a mistake the padres
make them pay for it austin nola
it's nice to see them take advantage of
the air the angels left out their form
second nola at first still none out
here's grisham lefty to lefty first
pitch were not grounded to first base in
between hop for walsh goes down to
second one return throw to first is wide
and gets away on his way home hosmer he
will score without a throw boy i don't
even know why they would ever try to
turn two there and they didn't even come
close
[Applause]
second error of the inning
and now a five to nothing padre lead
austin nola bats now with the bases
loaded and swings at this one and pops
it in the air into right center field
and making a lunging catch on that one
is joe adele and that is how the inning
will end
well that'll do it
they end up leaving the bases loaded to
the padres here in the sixth inning and
they've already stranded nine base
runners we're headed to the bottom of
the six angels need runs trailing
five nothing
two strikes to brandon marsh with two
outs here in the seventh
foul tip held onto by nola that is
strikeout number seven for joe mosgrove
who's threw seven in anaheim five
nothing padres
[Music]
they
are quijada strikes out
3-2
got him
down goes fatis
[Applause]
it's a good fastball rides upstairs 95
against a great fastball hitter but it
got it by him
he had it
firm at 95.
outside corner
the idol strikes out
cronin work
five-nothing padres
nice in there for strike three and for
musgrove that strikeout number eight of
the night one down
[Applause]
well what does he go to here
spins it up there you bet
freezes him stassi back to the dugout
joe musgrove is cruising
on the ground and muskrat can't get it
kim picks and throws in time
again hassan kim coming across to cut it
off and he makes the good throw to end
the inning
he's made some great plays at third base
for the padres tonight
see if the angels are going to challenge
this or not
do or die play and it's very close
incredible play
the curveball's been the pitch of the
night why not finish it off with a nice
yakker right here
swinging a miss and upton strikes out
that's the ball game
nine strikeouts for joe muscov who goes
the distance on 111 pitches
so the second complete game for the
padres this year and guess what no no
joe's got them both
you